I think we have to give a blonde person
number three hi I'm Iike I'm really like
bento boxes recently I found some super
super super cute ones
on the internet so I decided to
challenge myself to see if I could make
a super cute bento box I've never made
bento boxes before I definitely don't
think it's going to be easy I'm hoping
that my bento box looks at least a
little bit presentable a bento box that
hopefully people will think is too cute
to eat all right so let's go
so the first step before I did anything
else was to buy a bento box this is my
bento box if you make a cute bento your
bento box has to be cute I also got a
couple of shape cutouts including this
Panda face one flower star cutouts and
some cute faces the bento box materials
also came with a pair of tweezers and a
pin I don't know what this pin is gonna
be used for the next thing was to buy
ingredients so I got carrots I got
Tomatoes kale cheese ham and sausages
rice seaweed and some tofu skin let's
get started so I'm gonna start off with
the little sausages we're gonna create
little octopus I'm supposed to just cut
eight feet out I tore his leg I don't
know how I ready my stove maybe I should
do this this is not safe it legs I'm
also gonna prep the eggs we're gonna
make an egg omelet a lot of bento boxes
that I saw on the internet include this
it looks pretty and it's a great source
of protein I'm gonna add some dried
vegetables I am like the colombia's
person in the world
wait it's been 20 minutes I think as I
drop stuff it'll all be a breeze from
here I'm sure
all right sausages looks like your
little octopus
alright think that's done gonna let them
cool down a little bit mixed up make the
egg omelette I've only done this like
two times before please don't burn
slowly fold this up oh my god then we
got to do it again I really want to get
that nice layered oval shape that I see
in the bento box videos egg we have the
first two things done so what I'm gonna
try and do right now is to shape little
rice balls oh my god
the rice is all cut my help me help you
become human beings squish we have our
rice balls so now what I'm gonna try to
do is to form little hats with this put
it on top of the rice ball think of like
a tofu skin beanie you want to do
something like this
this is not my trick I learned it from
YouTube guys this is a slippery not as
quick as I thought it would be we're
trying to put the beanies on the little
rice balls put that in there OOP
now it looks like a little hat keeping
the rice ball warm I'm gonna cut out
faces for both the rice ball beings and
also the Hat so I'm gonna use the ham
and the cheese and then for little
details I'll have to cut it out and say
seaweed this should be pretty simple
it's just cutting shapes out right how
do I get this out this is what this is
all right
oh yes perfect cheese circle it's like
glue Mayo is my glue right now there we
go I feel like these beanies are giving
up on me too
[Music]
okay
I'm not touching it again I don't want
to don't want to destroy it then we're
gonna do the eyes for the little
sausages my hands are shakin looks like
eyeballs they're kind of creeping okay
just gonna cut out some cheeks here we
go they're not the best looking things
but they look presentable this is taking
a lot more time than I thought it would
I'm making good progress so I got a
piece of seaweed we're gonna try cutting
out these faces nope didn't make a dent
in it try any other face how long should
I do this for it should work Amazon said
they would work Amazon never lies colic
middle oh I just broke it
[Music]
this is my backup and if this doesn't
work I'm gonna run out and get something
else
I don't know what
[Music]
that sounds promising
yes yeah from the mouths
my hands are legit shape there we go
first mouth yes um eyes right now
can you just a bigger eyes because I
can't cut Hey
I just fly ours how is it possible that
people do this every day
[Music]
they like you right now I'm just gonna
finish off the sausage eyes guys the
octopus has arrived
oh yes I'm just gonna cut up the egg cut
up the carrots and we're gonna put them
all together I am so tired my back hurts
but I feel so accomplished let's
assemble put some kale in start by
putting in the little people I'm gonna
put in the eggs and then we're gonna put
in the little sausages cherry tomatoes
last thing the pretty flower carrots and
there you have it kind of cute I'm
pretty proud of myself I spent two and a
half hours I did not expect to be here
for so long big shout out to people who
do this every day she's so much respect
for you will I ever do this for my kids
no I am done I'm done
so this was fun do I want to eat this no
because I think it's a little too cute
let me know what you think should I do
this again please say no and uh yeah
thank you for watching me fail
[Music]